el presidente Turco Regio erdogan
interrumpe una entrevista
el estado de salud de erdogan ha sido
tema de discusión nacional previo a las
elecciones presidenciales el 14 de mayo
luego de haber cancelado algunos eventos
de campaña y de no haber asistido a la
inauguración de la primera central
nuclear turca en compañía de su homólogo
ruso Vladimir Putin el ministro de salud
intentó acabar las especulaciones sobre
el estado del candidato a la reelección
el estado de salud del presidente es
totalmente satisfactorio los efectos de
la infección gastrointestinal que tuvo
disminuyeron retomará sus actividades lo
antes posible la campaña no ha sido muy
favorecedora un devastador terremoto que
dejó 50.000 muertos en medio de críticas
a su gestión del desastre el deterioro
de la situación de derechos humanos con
cerca de 150 abogados periodistas y
políticos detenidos y la persecución
contra el pueblo kurdo han desgastado la
imagen del presidente ultraconservador
que ha acumulado más de una década en el
poder
las encuestas aventajan al Principal
líder de oposición que mal clic daroglu
líder del partido republicano del pueblo
mientras que ercm y mamoglu del mismo
partido y alcalde de Estambul fue
inhabilitado y no podrá presentarse a
los comicios el escenario electoral en
Turquía preocupa la Unión Europea
las elecciones se desarrollan en un
contexto muy difícil y retador por la
situación democrática de derechos
humanos y del Estado de derecho la
situación no es como la quisiéramos
en el exterior Ya comenzaron las
votaciones